meet Alan can cross for the past 21
years he's and shirt matches at Berlin's
Olympic Stadium run smoothly when is the
tournament the tournament is in two
weeks I need a week and a half for
everything to work in the plant so the
plant will grow the color will come I
can get the right cut so all these
things have got to be taken into
consideration before you actually
present the field for the tournament
gone are the days of simply using
fertilizers and lawn mowers technology
has evolved and so has current crosses
job these days more players expect and
demand the ideal playing surface because
when the grass is dry the ball tends to
slow down a lot so most players would
like the top surface to be a little bit
moist I know that the goalkeepers likely
to be able to be moist because they can
hold on to it better when it's a shot in
their direction the grass has accorded
almost wholly status this is how close
we can get to it no one apart from the
groundskeeper and his clothes staff
allowed to set foot on it ahead of the
final but he made an exception this time
just for DW can you enjoy football when
you're watching it are you too concerned
about the ground hit the nail on the
head i watch the football but I also
watched what their feet are doing on the
grass and I'm not very happy when the
feet start damaging the grass that's not
not doesn't make me happy I'd like to
see a football game and I'd love to see
the field as it looks today after the
game they're not be happy then I could
watch football and then relax the
Scotsman's resume is impressive world
cup final german cup finals and the
Bundesliga but there's one nagging item
still on his wish list the only thing
missing from my portfolio is the
Olympics if I get the Olympics which is
very unlikely in my time but if I had
the Olympics than my portfolio is full
live done everything and his pitches
Testament that practice really does make
perfect when you're watching the nlm
señor Carlos Tevez glide across this
immaculate turf on Saturday evening
spare a thought for the men and women
who helped make it possible olema hatake
reporting for DW
Berlin's Olympic Stadium